don't you love it when arrogant
egomaniacs are hoisted on their own
petard FBI director James Comey and
deputy director Andrew McCabe now know
the pain of those petard
the Department of Justice is
investigating Andrew McCabe now after an
Obama appointed IG made a criminal
referral and pompous Cardinal Comey is
now being investigated for leaking
classified information and commis memos
were released this week and they were
supposed to lay out the real reason for
his firing that donald trump was
colluding with the russians and donald
trump was looking to obstruct justice
well unfortunately for the democrats and
the mainstream media they proved just
the opposite and they go against
virtually everything that Comey is said
about Trump now because they didn't
trust the president Comey made notes of
his presidential meetings the memos were
written contemporaneous with the
meetings one within five minutes of the
meeting contemporaneous notes carry
great weight because they're made almost
immediately after the event when the
memory is fresh but unfortunately for
Jim Comey they do not support his
narrative in fact they proved the
opposite they proved one that the
president encouraged the FBI director to
investigate the issue of collusion
between anyone on the Trump campaign in
Russia
number two the president encouraged the
FBI director to investigate this Steele
dossier and number three the president
wanted to make sure that his
administration was free of leaks and
here's the rub the meeting with the
president by Comey was a setup to allow
CNN to go forward with a negative story
about the president and to create the
illusion of Russia collusion Comey
himself admits the president CNN wants
to go forward with a story because some
leaker gave them the dossier but there
needs to be a news hook so the meeting
for the discussion about the dossier
would be the hook and four days later
CNN had the story that Comey told the
president about that salacious dossier
and Comey himself was the one who
created the hook but folks it gets even
better James clapper the man I told you
last week that Jim Comey said he admires
most in government who we already know
is a liar based on his we don't spy on
Americans well move not wittingly at
least clapper told Comey to meet with
the president to speak about the dossier
Comey is dumb enough to admit it in the
memo he then says this is Comey speaking
I then executed the session exactly as I
had planned I said the Russians
allegedly had the tapes involving him
and prostitutes in Moscow so that they
could lend credence to the hyped up
Russian collusion investigation Trump
however interjects saying tor never
prostitutes Comey lied and said the FBI
is keeping a close hold on that dossier
so there would be no excuse for it to
expose this story so let me make it real
simple
clapper tells Comey to meet with the
President to alert him about the
prostitutes which is a pretext to create
a news hook so that CNN can leak the
story about the prostitutes but once
Comey is fired he decides he's going to
leak information to get to the New York
Times now that the Department of Justice
is looking at that leak of classified
information my judgment was I needed to
get that out into the public square and
so I asked a friend of mine to share the
content of the memo with a reporter
didn't do it myself for a variety of
reasons by asked him to because I
thought that might prompt the
appointment of a special counsel and so
I asked a close friend of mine to do it
Jim you're the head of the FBI you told
the president in that memo repeatedly
your memos that the president wasn't
under investigation
you get fired now you need to put things
in the public square to get a special
counsel why your memo the first one was
actually sent to the FBI to McCabe and
Company and since there clearly wasn't
anything criminal in that memo then
what's with your hogwash about you need
to get information into the public
square to get a special counsel
appointed Jim it's so obvious you're
fired and you're mad you're a liar and
you're a leaker your pompous your
egotistical your condescending and you
violate the very laws that you're sworn
to uphold because you want to make news
because you want to write a book because
you want to be a hero and because you
don't think the rules apply to you and
because you like your friend McCabe
according to the Inspector General do it
for personal gain
newsflash you didn't have a right to
leak that information once you took
those memos out of the building to leak
to the New York Times you James Comey
committed a crime you had no right to do
that they were not personal notes they
were not memos to yourself
they were memos to other FBI agents and
if Donald Trump needed investigating Jim
answer me this
why didn't you investigate him when you
were the highest ranking law enforcement
official in the nation why because there
was no investigation that was needed and
it was secondary in any event it was
phony you needed to make yourself the
protagonist and now we know the buck for
those memos in your illegal leaked to
the New York Times
Robert Muller wouldn't be doing what
he's doing and that is tearing at the
fabric of this country and ain't it
bittersweet irony Jim the both you and
McCabe are being looked at for the same
thing that Hillary was looked at you're
in the same boat as she but you let her
loose because you said she didn't intend
to have classified information on her
server but Jim you hoisted yourself on
your own petard
when
made it clear that you intended to
release those classified memos so that
you could get even with the president
you establish the intent that you say
was missing in Hillary's case Jim the
FBI is not proud of you you're a former
FBI director out there discussing
matters presently under investigation
as a special counsel is doing that very
thing where do you come off publishing a
book about issues under investigation
even admitting that what you lead to is
secret and therefore classified but you
protest
I don't do sneaky things I don't leak I
don't make weasel moves Jimmy you schizo
on the one hand you lie to the president
that you don't leak and the whole point
of the memo was to leak it and now on
your book tour you say it's true I am a
leaker and Jim you're a political
operative - you wanted Hillary Clinton
to be President you even changed the
definition of the law - let her get away
with it and you played along with
Loretta Lynch so that she could get away
with that do you think we'd be a lot
better off with Hillary Clinton as
president than Donald Trump
certainly given her commitment to our
traditions and our norms and our values
and the rule of law yes her commitment
to the rule of law
Jim you also have to keep your facts
straight the same day you the you said
Hillary would be a better president
Uddhav er and say it's too hard to go
back in time and answer whether she'd be
a better president when asked a few
hours earlier Jim do your answers depend
on the time of day or on medication Jim
it isn't working you're trying to look
like an objective individual until you
again admit that you're not I see the
Republican Party as near as I can tell
reflects now entirely Donald Trump's
values which is it doesn't reflect
values at all it's transactional it's
ego driven it's in service to his ego
so she'd be a better president but Jim
you need to be careful you need to be
very very careful you knew from the
get-go that you were going to cut
Hillary loose and you loose you knew
from your time in the Obama
administration that you would go after
Donald Trump you've deceived the
American people and as a result you the
director of the FBI are under
investigation for leaking classified
information you could be looked at for
theft of government property obstruction
of justice yourself and a clear abuse of
power and if I were a betting woman I'd
better that your friend clapper is
another one soon to be under
investigation and the bittersweet irony
for all Americans is that we will be
able to watch you fight each other
Andrew McCabe who says you told them
repeatedly that it was okay to leak to
the Wall Street Journal and Loretta
Lynch whom you accused of pressuring you
not to call Hillary's case an
investigation so now folks the whole
idea of Russian collusion with the
Donald Trump campaign bathes into
obscurity we now know and we now see the
deep state doing what it does best
state actors protecting each other and
like-minded members of the system but if
there's any justice and the Department
of Justice is independently run you'll
all be made accountable and finally Jim
you've done more damage to the FBI is an
institution than J Edgar Hoover because
your mission was to change the course of
American presidential history the only
difference between you and J edgar is
that he wore dresses and even if you
wanted to you probably couldn't get one
to fit you at six feet eight inches and
that's my open tell me what you think on
my facebook twitter and instagram
hashtag judge Janine